asbestos is a dangerous cancer-causing  substance although the EU banned all  forms of asbestos in 2005. people are  still dying from being exposed to  asbestos at work in the past  this is because it takes on average 30  years for the first signs of the  asbestos related illness to show  and many older buildings containing  asbestos still need to be renovated  so to protect people and the environment  from asbestos especially as we strive  for energy efficient buildings under the  eu's renovation wave the European  commission proposes actions to screen  asbestos in buildings safely dispose of  asbestos support asbestos victims  collect and share data on buildings from  their design to demolition the  commission also proposes to lower  substantially the existing exposure  limit value for asbestos  actions we take 9 will protect our  future Generations  we need to ensure an asbestos free  Europe  [Music]